[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Mitri Serien schönen guten Abend ihnen
allen mit mir im Studios Katja stresort
später die Höhepunkte im Sport so
sieht's aus schönen guten Abend dann
blicken wir gemeinsam auf die Themen des
Tages
Drohnen Angriff auf Moskau der Kreml
beschuldigt die Ukraine hier erklärt man
habe mit dem Vorfall nichts zu tun
eine Region in Aufruhr im Kosovo spitzt
sich der Konflikt zwischen Serben und
Albanern weiter zu die Nato will nun
mehr Soldaten stationieren
und tödliche Badeunfälle an Pfingsten
die DLRG waren immer weniger Kinder
können schwimmen
[Musik]
es ist bemerkenswert nicht weit weg von
Putins wochenendresidenz hat es seit
Kriegsbeginn den wohl größten
Luftangriff auf Moskau gegeben Russland
spricht von Terror durch die Regierung
in Kiew alle acht Drohnen sein
unschädlich gemacht worden es habe zwei
Verletzte und leichte Gebäude schädigt
gegeben nach zuletzt vermehrten Attacken
auf Russland könnte die Verunsicherung
in der Bevölkerung nun steigen
Christkind
plötzlich ist der Krieg auch in Moskau
ganz nah am frühen Morgen werden mehrere
Drohnenangriffe gemeldet eine
gewohnhäuser werden leicht beschädigt
die Leute haben geschlafen da war so ein
Summen und dann hat es laut gekracht als
wäre etwas eingeschlagen
der Kreml spricht von einem
terroristischen Angriff beschuldigt die
Ukraine die Regierung dort bestreitet
zumindest direkt beteiligt zu sein
im Gegensatz zu diesen Angriffen vor dem
9 mai handelt es sich jetzt ja um
größere Drohnen die die Reichweite haben
aus der Ukraine auch nach Moskau zu
fliegen das war nichts relativ eindeutig
ukrainische Drohnen
der Drohnen und Einschläge haben in
Moskau Spuren hinterlassen die Wirkung
der Angriffe aber vor allem
psychologisch Kriegslärm und schlaflose
Nächte haben die meisten Moskauer noch
nicht erlebt
in Kiew dagegen kennen sie das nur als
so gut Nacht für Nacht neue Drohnen
dieses Mal wurde laut Bürgermeister
Klitschko ein Mensch getötet zu den
Angriffen in Moskau sagt er
aber ich Informationen bekommen dass es
eine
Angriff am moskop gewesen und Moskau
auch nie geschlafen und nicht mal denke
ich mal hier den Moskau kam ein bisschen
jede Burge von unserer Stadt stehen was
bedeutet das der russische Präsident
meldet sich am Nachmittag Putin lobt die
Flugabwehr sagt aber auch wir werden sie
noch besser machen
wir wollen nachfragen
was kannst du uns über die
Drohnenangriffe und die Reaktion in
Moskau berichten
ja besonders brisant an der Geschichte
sind die genauen Orte an denen diese
Drohnen eingeschlagen haben ob sie
abgeschossen wurden oder abgestürzt sind
das lässt sich nicht in jedem Fall sagen
klar ist aber das auch Wohngebiete
betroffen waren die bekannt dafür sind
dass dort die russische Wirtschafts- und
Polit Elite ihre Anwesen hat eine Drohne
soll auch nur wenige Kilometer von
Putins Residenz niedergegangen sein
trotz oder vielleicht auch gerade wegen
dieser Massivität dieser Angriffe
scheinen die offiziellen Stellen heute
besonders bemüht darum routiniert zu
wirken und einigermaßen besonnen auf
diesen auf diese Vorfälle zu reagieren
in der russischen Bevölkerung wiederum
da hört man jetzt immer öfter besorgte
Stimmen ganz sicherlich auch wegen der
vielen Zwischenfälle die es in den
grenznahen Regionen gibt ähm fühlen sich
die Menschen immer mehr angegriffen und
für diese Angriffe oder für die Tatsache
dass ihr Land überhaupt zum Ziel von
Angriffen wird machen dann aber viele
wenn nicht die meisten Russinnen und
Russen die Ukraine und den Westen
verantwortlich für vielen Dank nach
Moskau und um den Drohnen Angriff auf
Moskau geht es dann auch bei den
Kollegen von ZF heute live eine
verteidigungsexpertin beantwortet die
wichtigsten Fragen ab 19.30 auf unseren
Social Media Kanälen und in der ZDF
heute-app ja je länger der Ukraine Krieg
dauert desto größer werden die
Erwartungen der baltischen Nachbarn an
die Nato und damit auch an Deutschland
Litauen will das möglichst viele
Deutsche Soldatinnen und Soldaten auf
Dauer präsent sind
760 gehören bereits einem dort von der
bundeswehrgeführten nato-kampfverband an
bei einem Besuch auf dem
Truppenübungsplatz papprade nahe der
Grenze zu Belarus brachte
Bundespräsident Steinmeier erstmals
Angehörige der Soldaten mit Patricia
Wiedemeier
selten begann eine Reise des
Bundespräsidenten so emotional zwölf
Angehörige von den Litauen stationierten
Soldaten durften mitfliegen nach Vilnius
steht Visite für 24 Stunden eine
besondere Geste der Anerkennung für das
was die Bundeswehr im Ausland Leiste so
Steinmeier die Freude groß ebenso die
Erwartungen schließlich haben sie sich
vier bis sechs Monate nicht gesehen
auch drei Kinder und ja dass man so ein
bisschen so Familiensachen besprechen
kann und einfach sich auch mal annehmen
kann die Reise ist
aufregenden Mann zu treffen weil den
kenne ich
ja da weiß ich ja was mich erwartet also
da freue ich mich drauf danke und
Anerkennung für die deutsche Hilfe auch
vom litauischen Präsidenten nauseder
Russland und die Ukraine sind nah die
Ängste vor einem russischen Überfall
groß und es Präsident Steinmeier sicher
Litauen jegliche Unterstützung zu
Deutschland steht zu seiner
Verantwortung in der NATO in Europa
gemeinsam werden wir jeden
Quadratzentimeter des
nato-bündnisgebietes
verteidigend am Nachmittag dann auf dem
Truppenübungsplatz paparade nahe der
weißrussischen Grenze Vorstellung des
multi-nationalen beweglichen
gefechtsstandes hier üben deutsche
Niederländer und Kroatien zusammen
760 deutsche Soldatinnen und Soldaten
sind hier in Litauen stationiert fest
vereinbart ist eine Aufstockung auf 3
bis 5000 zum Schutz der nato-ostflanke
doch wann und vor allen Dingen wie in
welcher Form das passieren wird das ist
nach wie vor offen und bleibt umstritten
am Ende des Tages dann ein erneutes
Treffen mit den Angehörigen
eine kleine Geste für den Job den die
Soldaten hier leisten
Millionen Hausbesitzer fragen sich wie
wird das geplante heizungsgesetz der
Regierung genau aussehen heute abend
berät Wirtschaftsminister Habig mit
seinen Koalitionspartnern darüber die
FDP hatte den Gesetzentwurf ja wegen
grundsätzlicher Bedenken blockiert und
danach hat es in der Ampel wieder mal
gekracht vor allem grüne warfen der FDP
Wortbruch vor inzwischen stehen die
Zeichen wieder auf Kompromiss mehr von
ihnen ist Trumps
Schluss soll sein mit Koalitionsstreit
konstruktiv soll es hier heute im
Wirtschaftsministerium zugehen Minister
Habeck hat Fachpolitiker der einzelnen
Fraktionen für den Abend eingeladen er
selber macht bereits
Kompromissvorschläge per Videobotschaft
vier Bereiche sehe ich vor allem über
die noch einmal gesprochen werden kann
und wo verbesser aus
Nachbesserungsbedarf offensichtlich
besteht so könnte das Startdatum für
Altbauten nach hinten verschoben werden
mehr technologieoffenheit soll es geben
so könnten auch Holzpellets erlaubt sein
die Planungen für Kommunen will Harbeck
auf die für private Hausbesitzer
abstimmen und Härtefallregelungen
nachbessern bei der FDP bisher der
Blockierer des Gebäude Energiegesetzes
kommt die nun diskutierte Kopplung mit
der wärmeplanung der Kommunen gut an
es geht darum das Kommunen selber sich
überlegen wie die wo geht die Reise hin
baue ich ein Gas Netz baue ich
fernwärmen zu und wenn die Menschen
wissen was in der Kommune passieren wird
also gibt es ab 2035 noch die
Möglichkeit Gasheizung dann mit
Wasserstoff zum Beispiel zu betreiben
dann können wir den Leuten auch wirklich
dann können wir dieses Gesetz auch
wirklich Scharfstellen klar ist alles
Seiten versuchen derzeit zu dskalieren
ich würde sagen schon in den letzten
Tagen hat man gemerkt die Rhetorik hat
sich bei vielen deutlich verändert von
der
verweigerungskommunikation ist es zu
ermöglichungskommunikation übergegangen
vom ursprünglichen Fragen Katalog der
FDP sind 77 Fragen an habe ich übrig sie
sollen heute beantwortet werden
Ergebnisse werden vom Treffen im
Wirtschaftsministerium noch nicht
erwartet
also Ergebnisse werden nicht erwartet
Deo call in Berlin was darf man denn
erwarten
und ich glaube man darf zumindest
erwarten dass in der Ampel die Zahl der
gerauchten Friedenspfeifen weiter
zunimmt und die der Kriegs maskierten
abnimmt aktuell wird vielfältig und in
mehreren Formaten miteinander geredet
sich informiert und auch in der Sache
verhandelt nachdem wochenlangen kracht
zeigen ja mittlerweile die Umfragen dass
die Ampel keine eigene Mehrheit mehr
hätte und dass viele Bürger mit der
Arbeit der Koalition unzufrieden sind
oder wie ist der SPD-Vorsitzende ja
drastisch anmahnte der öffentliche
Streit hat die Bevölkerung derart
verunsichert wie ich es bei wenigen
Gesetzentwürfen zuvor erlebt habe die
von Robert Habeck schon am Freitag
angedeutetem kompromisse sind
offensichtlich Teil der laufenden
Verhandlungen aber sie dürften der FDP
noch nicht ausreichen denn sonst hätten
die Liberalen den quälenden Prozess ja
schon per Zustimmung beenden können
vielleicht braucht es am Ende dann doch
noch das leise Machtwort das Kanzlers
vielen Dank nach Berlin Teo
im Kosovo haben sich die Spannungen
zwischen Serben und Albanern in den
letzten Tagen zugespitzt darum will die
Nato ihre kv-schutztruppe vor Ort
verstärken bei Zusammenstößen wurden
gestern rund 30 Nato-Soldaten verletzt
Kosovo hat sich 2008 für unabhängig
erklärt Serbien erkennt das aber nicht
an auch weil im Norden mehrheitlich
Serben Leben deren Wut Ende zündet sich
jetzt daran dass Kandidaten aus der
albanischen Volksgruppe zu Bürgermeister
gewählt wurden Wolf Christian Ulrich
berichtet
verletzte KV Soldaten am Boden sie
sollen für Frieden sorgen und sind jetzt
Zielscheibe wie die Tante Serben in
Kosovo neue Eskalation im Streit um die
Unabhängigkeit von Kosovo nun
gegenseitig Schuldzuweisungen erst
Serbiens Präsident das ist alles von
Kosovos Albin Kurti gesteuert der einen
Konflikt zwischen Serbien und der Natur
will und Kosovos Ministerpräsident Kurti
antwortet in einer Demokratie gibt es
keinen Platz für faschistische Gewalt
es begann mit dem Kommunalwahlen in
nordkoro welche die Verben boykottierten
so gewann den kosovarische Bürgermeister
doch die wollen die Serben nicht
akzeptieren sie fordern mehr Autonomie
in ihren Gemeinden Kosovos Regierung
dagegen fürchte dass ich so ein Staat im
Staate betet Kosovo will das in von
Serben bewohnten Gemeinden kosovarisches
Recht durchgesetzt wird und das stört
sie sagen dort
wir fordern dass sich alle Mitglieder
der kosovarischen Sonderpolizei aus
Gemeinden mit serbischer Mehrheit
zurückziehen so heute ein serbischer
Kommunalpolitiker
die EU und die USA riefen beide
Konfliktparteien heute zum Frieden auf
we have wir haben schon zu viel Gewalt
in Europa gerade wir können uns nicht
noch einen Konflikt leisten
die diplomatischen Drähte laufen heiß
die Emotionen in Kosovo heute etwas
abgekühlt doch die Gefahr einer ernsten
Eskalation bleibt greifbar die NATO
Stock deshalb jetzt die kv-truppen um
700 Soldaten auf
zurück nach Deutschland im vergangenen
Jahr ist die Zahl der Einbürgerungen
deutlich gestiegen nach Zahlen des
Statistischen Bundesamtes wurden mehr
als
168.000 Menschen deutsche 28% mehr als
2021 Syrer und syrerinnen machten mit
einem Anteil von 29% die größte Gruppe
aus ja eingebürgert werden will braucht
ausreichende Sprachkenntnisse einen
gesicherten Lebensunterhalt und muss in
der Regel seit mindestens acht Jahren
hier leben jetzt zu einem Steuerbetrug
der den Staat also uns alle viele
Milliarden kostet cumex lautet das
Stichwort das heißt
Kapitalertragssteuer wird nur einmal
gezahlt aber mehrfach vom Fiskus
zurückgefordert als Schlüsselfigur des
ganzen gilt der Steueranwalt hanno
Berger der nach einem ersten Urteil
bereits in Haft sitzt erst jetzt vom
Landgericht Wiesbaden zu einer
Freiheitsstrafe von 8 Jahren und drei
Monaten verurteilt worden
Sarah kacke
er hat ihn maßgeblich geplant und
organisiert den größten steuerraub in
der Geschichte der Bundesrepublik hanno
Berger Jurist und ehemaliger
Finanzbeamter deshalb soll er nun für
mehr als acht Jahre ins Gefängnis die
Kamera hat es als erwiesen angesehen
dass ein Modell dass die doppelte
Anrechnung von Kapitalertragsteuer zum
erklärten Ziel hat auch zum damaligen
Zeitpunkt
steuerstrafrechtlich relevant war und
in diesem Zuge hier zu Verurteilung
gelangt ist und so funktionierte das
System cumex Banken Aktienhändler und
steueranwälte schoben sich rund um den
dividendenstichtag trickreich
Aktienpakete hin und her so dass das
Finanzamt nicht mehr folgen konnte dabei
wird die fällige Steuer nur einmal
bezahlt am Ende vom Finanzamt aber
mehrfach zurückerstattet so entstand der
Allgemeinheit ein Schaden von etwa 10
Milliarden Euro einer der hauptdrazieher
in diesem gigantischen steuerraub ist
heute mit Hanno Berger verurteilt worden
aber es gibt mehr als 100 weitere
mutmaßliche Betrüger in diesem
cum-ex-komplex deren Verfahren noch
nicht abgeschlossen sind Schätzung
zufolge könnte daher die Verfolgung
aller möglichen cum-ex-straftäter bis zu
25 Jahre dauern denn das System cum-ex
war größer als hanno Berger
cumex-geschäfte die gibt es am Markt
seit rund 20 Jahren und es hat über zehn
Jahre gebraucht um diese Geschäfte
überhaupt zu entdecken und es ist nicht
auszuschließen dass diese Geschäfte in
abgewandelter Form immer noch passieren
können auch der Fall Berger ist noch
nicht abgeschlossen er will in Revision
gehen abschließend wird der
Bundesgerichtshof entscheiden
so wie erleben gerade schönes
sommerliches Wetter die ersten Baden
nicht nur schon in Freibädern sondern
auch in sehen und Flüssen zwei Tatsachen
können das aber höchst unsicher machen
zum einen sind immer mehr
Grundschulkinder nicht Schwimmer nämlich
20% und das Baden in Flüssen etwa am
Rhein ist gefährlicher als viele denken
es gab mehrere Tote an Pfingsten Martin
Honecker berichtet
es hätte ein schöner Familienausflug an
einen seitenamen des Rheins werden
sollen aber der Ende tragisch zwei
Kinder spielen am Pfingstmontag am Ufer
und werden mitgerissen der Vater springt
hinterher nur eines der Kinder kann sich
retten der Vater und ein siebenjähriger
Sohn sterben der Rhein birgt riesige
Gefahren sagt die Feuerwehr gerade wenn
Schiffe vorbeifahren die halt Wellen mit
sich bringen und im Nachgang halt einen
Sog wirken wird man ganz leicht ins
Wasser reingezogen
außerdem konnten weder Vater noch so
nach Angaben der Feuerwehr schwimmen das
geht vielen so
die Sonne scheint das Wasser lockt und
Badeseen Ludwigshafen Silla und Melissa
haben schwimmen gelernt und bleiben
trotzdem vorsichtig
am meisten so wie tief ist wie tief ich
reingehen kann wie tief wie tief es ist
und so wo stehen kann wo ich nicht
stehen kann und sowas
unter ihren Freunden können einige nicht
schwimmen haben Schwierigkeiten das
liegt auch daran dass es immer weniger
Schwimmbäder gebe um das zu lernen sagt
die DLRG letztendlich spielt aber auch
ein Corona ein Stück weit eine Rolle
nach dem neun Monate unter anderem die
Schwimmbäder geschlossen waren
fehlt einfach die Gewöhnung mit dem
Element Wasser aber auch wer schwimmen
kann kann verunglücken etwa durch einen
Kreislaufkollaps daher rät die DLRG am
besten nur dort schwimmen zu gehen wo es
eine Badeaufsicht gibt
dem Schauspieler peter Simonischek ist
in seiner Karriere ein Kunststück
gelungen er war gleichermaßen beliebt
bei Fans der leichteren Komödie und bei
Freunden des Tiefgangs jetzt ist der im
Alter von 76 Jahren gestorben wichtig
bekannt machte ihn die Hauptrolle im
Oscar nominierten Film Toni Erdmann als
pensionierter Musiklehrer mit skurrilem
Humor zuvor hatte der Österreicher viele
Jahre an verschiedenen Theatern gespielt
als jedermann wurde er zu einem Star der
Salzburger Festspiele
jetzt sind wir beim Sport und Katjas
heißt jetzt kräftig durchatmen für
Tennisprofi Alexander das sieht aus
Deutschlands Nummer eins hat die erste
Runde der French Open überstanden es war
gegen den Südafrikaner Leute harry ist
kein Zauber Tennis er ein Kraftakt in
drei Sätzen genau 361 Tage nach seiner
schweren Knöchelverletzung von Paris
es war noch längst nicht alles Gold was
für Alexander Zverev in der Pariser
Sonne glänzte und doch war sein Wille
starker und sein Aufschlag vor allem der
zweite klar besser als der seines
Gegenübers des Südafrikaners Leute
Harrys
mit dem sieben zu sechs sieben zu sechs
und sechs zu eins erfolgt über Harris
ist Alexander Zverev zumindest den
Zahlen nach ein guter Start ins Turnier
gelungen
ihm bleibt aber sicher noch eine Menge
Potenzial um auch die kommenden Aufgaben
in der Pariser Sonne zu meistern
zum Fußball Jörg Schmadtke wird neuer
Sportdirektor beim englischen Top-Club
FC Liverpool zunächst für nur drei
Monate beiderseitige Probezeit quasi und
die beginnt für den langjährigen
Bundesliga Manager beim Verein um
Trainer Jürgen Klopp bereits übermorgen
und ebenfalls am Donnerstag muss noch
Zweitligist Hamburger SV mal wieder in
die Relegation etwas dass der Verein nur
allzu gut kennt aus dem Vorjahr es soll
gegen den VfB Stuttgart allerdings
erfolgreicher laufen als damals gegen
Hertha BSC
Clara Fall von zu früh gefreut erst
schien der Aufstieg am Sonntag schon
sicher dann viele noch später
Heidenheimer Tore Wechselbad der Gefühle
das können sie beim HSV von ganz oben
bis ganz unten alles dabei es gibt immer
Schlimmeres im Leben sage ich
und trotzdem ich habe ja schon gesagt
zweiter oder weiter
also weiter keiner hat mehr
relegationserfahrung der HSV macht da
zum vierten Mal schon mit nach einer
Saison mit 20 Siegen hier haben auf
jeden Fall so viel zu bieten dass wir
diese Spiele auch für uns gestalten
können und wir fahren nach Stuttgart um
zu gewinnen dabei ist das Risiko gering
sich nochmal zu früh zu freuen es gibt
ja auf jeden Fall später noch das
Rückspiel
am Montag das wird spannend danke Katja
so das Wetter das wird noch besser
Einzelheiten hat gleich für Sie Katja
horneffer um 21 Uhr 45 erwartet Sie
Dunja Hayali wieder zum heute journal
wir vom gesamten heute 19 Team sagen
Danke schön fürs zuschauen entspannten
Abend und bis morgen
[Musik]
guten Abend morgen geht mit dem Mai auch
der meteorologische Frühling zu Ende es
war der nasseste Frühling seit zehn
Jahren jetzt im Mai gab es allerdings
große Unterschiede was den Regen an
betraf kaum 5 Liter Regen pro
Quadratmeter vielen hier im Nordosten in
den westlichen Mittelgebirgen und am
Alpenrand waren es zum Teil über 200
Liter pro Quadratmeter heute kam noch
ein bisschen Regen dazu aus diesen
Wolken hier in Schleswig-Holstein in
Niedersachsen und in Bremen schön zu
erkennen sind auch die Quellwolken hier
in Bayern dazu stiegen die Temperaturen
an der Nordsee bis 14 Grad und am
Oberrhein bis 26 Grad heute Nacht sinken
die wird im Rhein-Main-Gebiet auf 12
hier in der Uckermark auf drei Grad da
reicht's also tatsächlich noch mal für
Frost am Boden die Nacht ist klar es
gibt nur wenige Wolkenfelder und morgen
strahlt dann wieder die Sonne nur bei
Norddeutschland ziehen einige
Wolkenfelder hinweg und vielleicht kann
es aus den Alpen heraus mal für einen
kleinen Regenschauer reichen bei einem
winterfestlichen Richtung an der Nordsee
kommt der Wind immer noch aus
nordwestlichen Richtung und deswegen
bleibst du auch kalt mit 15 Grad sonst
werden 20 bis 26 am Oberrhein bis zu 28
Grad erreicht und dann diesem Wetter
ändert sich an den nächsten Tagen gar
nichts guten Abend